the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so this is a pretty key lecture this
lecture is about principle component
analysis PCA which is a major tool in in
understanding a matrix of data so what
what is PCA about well first of all let
me remember what was the whole point of
less yesterday's lecture the singular
value decomposition that any matrix a
could be broken into are rank one pieces
or being the rank of the matrix and each
piece has you times of V transpose and
the good special thing is the user
orthonormal and also the V's are also
normal ok so that's the whole matrix but
we have a big matrix and we want to get
the important information out of it not
all the information and people say if if
in in machine learning if you've learned
all the training data you haven't
learned anything really
you've just like copied it all in you
the whole point of of neural nets and
the process of machine learning is to
learn important facts about the data and
now here we're at the most basic stage
of that and I claim that the important
facts about the matrix are in its
largest k singular values the largest k
pieces we can take k equal 1 would tell
us the largest single piece but maybe we
have space and computing power to handle
a hundred pieces so I would take k equal
100 the
matrix might have ranked thousands so I
claim that a K is the best now here's
the one theorem for today that a K using
the first the first K pieces of the SVD
is the best approximation to a of rank K
so I'll write that down so that's that
really says why the SVD is perfect okay
so that's that statement says that if if
be another matrix has rank K then the
distance from A to B the error you're
making in just using B that error is
greater than or equal to the error you
make for the best guidance so that's a
pretty straightforward beautiful fact
and it goes back to people who
discovered the SVD in the first place
but then a couple of psychologists gave
a proof in a later paper and it's often
called the Eckert young theorem
there's the theorem isn't that
straightforward and the hypothesis is
straightforward that's pretty nice but
of course we have to think why is it
true why is it true and to give meaning
to the theorem we have to say what these
double bars are do you know the right
name for this so that double bar around
a matrix is called the the norm of the
matrix the norm so I have to say
something about matrix norms
how big is that's a measure of how big
it is and what I have to say is
there are many different measures of a
matrix how large that matrix is let me
tell you for today three possible
measures of a matrix so different ways
to measure and me I'll call the matrix
just a maybe but then I'm gonna apply
the measure to a minus B and to a minus
a K and show that that is the smaller
okay so I'm on to tell you about the
norm of a about some possible norms of a
and actually the norms I'm going to take
today will be will have this special
feature that they can be found computed
by their singular values so let me
mention the the l2 norm that is the
largest singular value so that's an
important measure of the sort of the
size of a matrix I'm talking here yeah
about a general M by n matrix a sigma
one is the is an important norm often
called the l2 norm and that's where that
index 2 goes oh I should really start
with vectors norms of vectors and then
build two norms of matrices let me do
norms of vectors over on this side the
l2 norm of a vector do we know what that
is that's the regular length of the
vector that we all expect the square
root of v1 squared up to VN square the
hypotenuse the length of the hypotenuse
in n-dimensional space that's the l2
norm because of that to the l1 norm of a
vector is just add up those pieces
without squaring and square rooting them
just add them that's the l1 norm
and you might say why do we want to
norms or there are more norms let me
just tell you one more the infinity norm
and there's a reason for the one and the
two and the infinity is the largest of
the beasts okay
have you met norms before I don't know
these are vector norms but maybe you
have met then we're going to have matrix
norms that maybe will be new so this is
the norm that we usually think of but
this one has become really really
important and let me tell you just why
and then we'll a later section of the
notes and a later lecture in this course
we'll develop that develop this this is
the l1 norm so this is l2 l1 and L
infinity so what's special about this
one well it just turned out and it was
only discovered you know in our
lifetimes that when you minimize some
function using the l1 norm you're in a
minimize some say signal noise or
whatever you minimize some function if
you use l1 the winning vector the
minimizing vector turns out to be sparse
and what a sparse mean sparse means
mostly 0 components somehow when I
minimize in l2 which which is
historically goes back to Gauss the
greatest mathematician of all time when
you minimize something in l2 you do
least squares and you find that the guy
that gives you the minimum has a lot of
little numbers a lot of little
components because when you square those
little ones they they
don't hurt much but gals so galas didn't
do least l1 norm that has different
names basis pursuit and and it comes
into signal processing and sensing right
and then it was discovered that if you
minimize as we'll see in that norm you
amazingly get the winning vector has
much mostly zeros and the advantage of
that is that you can understand what its
components are the one with many small
components you're like he have no
interpretation for that answer but for
an answer that just has a few nonzero
components you really see what's
happening and then this is a important
one too ok ok now I'm gonna turn just to
so what's the property of a norm well
you can see that the norm of C times a
vector is just multiplying by 6 or 11 or
minus pi or whatever is the size of C
norms have that nice property they're
they're homogeneous or whatever word if
you mull the vector you should double
the norm that double the length that
makes sense and then the important
property is that is the famous triangle
inequality that if you if V and W are
two sides of a triangle and you take the
norm of V and add to the norm of W the
two sides you get more than the straight
norm along the hypotenuse yeah so those
are properties that we require and and
and and the fact that the norm is
positive which is I won't write down but
it's important to okay so those are
norms and those will apply also to
maitre
Norm's so if I double the matrix I want
to double its norm and of course that
works for the tomb norm and actually
probably so the triangle inequality for
this norm is saying that the largest
singular value of a plus B two matrices
is less or equal to the largest singular
value of a plus the largest singular
value of B and that's we we won't take
class time to check minor it
straightforward things like that
so now I'm gonna continue with that
three norms that I want to tell you
about that's a very important one then
there's another norm that's named as an
F and it's named after fro B Gnaeus
sorry about that
and what is that norm that norm looks at
all the entries in the matrix just like
it was a long vector and squares them
all and adds them up so in a way it's
like the two norm for a vector it's so
the squared or shall I put square root
maybe I should it's the square root of
all the little people in in the matrix
so a 1 n squared plus the next a 2 1
squared and so on you finally get to a M
N squared you you all you just treat the
matrix like a long vector and take this
square root just just like so that's
that's the Frobenius norm and then
finally not not so well known is
something that's more like L one it's
called the nuclear norm
and not all the faculty would know about
this nuclear norm so it is the sum of
the Sigma of the singular values I guess
there are of them so that's where we
would stop oh okay
so those are three norms now why why do
I pick on those three norms and and
here's the point that though for those
three norms this statement is true I
could cook up other matrix norms for
which this wouldn't work but for these
three highly important norms this
Eckhart Jung statement that the closest
rank K approximation is found from the
first K pieces yeah you see that's a
good thing because this is what we
compute from the SVD so now we've solved
an approximation problem we found the
Benham the best B is a K and the point
is it could use all the any of those
norms so there would be a well somebody
finally came up with a proof that would
that does all three norms at once in the
notes I do that one separately from
Frobenius and actually I found in an MIT
thesis just I was just reading a course
six PhD thesis and the author who's
speaking tomorrow in and or Friday in in
idss dr. cerebro found a nice new proof
of Frobenius and it's in the notes as
well as the an older proof okay you know
as I talk here I'm not too sure whether
it is essential for me to go through the
proof
either in the l2 norm which takes half a
page in the notes or in the Frobenius
norm which takes more I'd rather you see
the point the point is that in these
norms and now what is special about
these norms of a matrix these depend
only on their Sigma's only on this oh
I'll finish that sentence because it was
true these these norms depend only on
the singular values right
that one at least depends only on a
singular value it's the largest one this
one is the sum of them all this one
comes into the Netflix competition by
the way this was the right norm to win
zillion dollars in the Netflix
competition so what did Netflix put it
did a math competition it had movie
preferences from many many Netflix
subscribers they gave their ranking to a
bunch of movies but of course they
hadn't seen No none of them had seen all
the movies so the matrix of rankings
where you had the rancor and the matrix
was a very big matrix but it's got
missing entries if the rancor didn't see
the movie
he isn't he or she isn't ranking it so
what's the idea about Netflix so they
offered a like a million dollar prize
and a lot of math and computer science
people fought for that prize and over
the years they got like higher 92 93 94
percent right so but it turned out that
this was well you had to in the end you
had to use a little psychology of how
people voted so it was partly about
human psychology but it was also a very
large matrix problem with an incomplete
matrix an incomplete matrix and so it
had to be completed you had to figure
out what would
ranker have said about the post if he
hadn't seen it but had ranked you know
several other movies like all the
President's Men or whatever given a
ranking to those you have to and that's
a recommender system of course that's
what that's how you get recommendations
from from Amazon
they've got a big matrix calculation
here and if you've bought a couple of
math books they're gonna tell you about
more math books more than you want to
know all right
yeah okay so anyway it just turned out
that this norm was the right one to
minimize I can't give you all the
details of the Netflix competition but
this turned out to be the right norm to
do a minimum problem a best not least
squares these squares would look at some
other norm but a best nuclear norm
completion of the matrix and and and now
it's a so now it's being put to much
more serious uses from for MRI magnetic
resonance stuff you know when you're go
in and get you it's a noisy system but
you get it it gives a excellent picture
of of what's going on so so I'll just
write netflix here so it gets in this
and then MRIs so what's the point about
MRIs so if you don't if you stay in long
enough you gotta come you get a you got
all the numbers aren't any there isn't
missing data but if you was with a child
you might want to just have the child in
for a few minutes then that's not enough
to get a complete picture and you have a
and missing data in your matrix of in
your your in the image from the MRI so
then of course you've got to complete
that matrix you have to fill in what
would the what would the MRI have seen
in those positions where it didn't look
long enough and again a nuclear norm is
the good one for that okay
so there's there there will be a whole
section on norms maybe just about in in
stellar by now okay so I'm not going to
let me just say like what does this what
does this say what does this tell us
so I'll just give an example maybe I'll
take start start with the example that's
in the notes suppose K is 2 so I'm
looking of among all rank two matrices
and suppose my matrix is 4 3 2 1 and all
the rest zeroes diag and it's a rank 4
matrix I can see it singular values
there sitting there
those would be the singular values and
the eigen values and everything of
course now what would be a 2 what would
be the best approximation of Rank 2 to
that matrix in in this sense to be
completed what would a to do yeah it
would be 4 and 3 it would pick the two
largest so I'm looking at a k-8 this is
cape of the 2 so it has to have a rank 2
this has got rank for the biggest pieces
are those
okay so this thing says that if I had
any other matrix B it would be further
away from a than this guy says that this
is the closest and I just like could
could you think of a matrix that could
possibly be closer and be ranked to that
rank two is the tricky thing the the
matrices of Rank 2 form a kind of crazy
set if I add a Rank 2 matrix to a Rank 2
matrix
probably the rank is up to 4 so so the
rank 2 matrices are all kind of floating
around and little in their own little
corners this looks like the best one but
in the notes I suggest well you could
get a rank to mate a rank I could or
what about B what about this B I for
this guy I could get closer
maybe not exact but closer maybe by
taking 3.5 3.5 oh but I only want to use
rank well I've only got to rank 2 to
play with so I better make this into a
right I have to like make this into a
rank one piece and then the 2 and the 1
so you see what I've what I thought of I
thought man maybe that's better like on
the diagonal I'm coming closer well I'm
not getting it exactly here but then
I've got one left to play with and I'll
put maybe 1.5 down here ok so that's a
rank 2 matrix 2 little rank ones and on
the diagonal it's better three-point
fives I'm only missing by 1/2 one point
5s I'm missing by half so I'm only
missing by half on the diagonal where
this guy was missing by 2 so maybe I've
found something better but I had to pay
a price of these things off the dying
to keep the ranked low and they kill me
so that be will be further away from a
the error if I computed a minus B and
computed its norm I would see bigger
than bigger than a - a - ؈ so you see
the point of the theorem that's that's
really what I'm trying to say that it is
not obvious you may you may feel well
it's totally obvious pick four and three
what else could do it but it depends on
the norm and so on so it's not a Kurt
Young had to think of a proof and other
people too okay so that's now but you
could say also say object that I started
with a diagonal matrix here that's so
special but what I want to say is the
diagonal matrix is not that special
because I could take a so let me doubt
just call this diagonal matrix D oh let
me call it Sigma to give it another sort
of appropriate name so like if I thought
of matrices what I want to say is this
could be the Sigma matrix and there
could be a you on the left of it and a
Sigma on the right of it so so about a
su Sigma V transpose so this is my Sigma
and this is like any orthogonal matrix U
and this is like any V transpose right
I'm just saying here's a whole lot more
matrices there's just one matrix but now
I have all these matrices with use
multiplying on the left and V transpose
on so on the right and I ask you this
question what are the singular values of
that matrix a here the singular values
were clear four three two and one
what are the singular values of this
matrix a when I've multiplied by a
orthogonal guy on both sides that's a
key question what are the singular
values of that one four three two one
didn't change why is that because the
singular values are the because this has
a SVD form orthogonal times diagonal
times orthogonal and that diagonal
contains the singular values what I'm
saying is that might an hour trivial
little example here actually was all
four by fours that have these singular
values I could my whole problem is
orthogonal e invariant tamasic I would
say when I multiply by U or a V
transpose or both the problem doesn't
change norms don't change yeah that's a
point yeah I realize it now this is the
point if I multiply the matrix a by by
an orthogonal matrix U it has all the
same norms doesn't change the norm
actually that was true way back for
vectors with with this length with this
length
what's the deal about vectors suppose I
suppose I have a vector V and I've
computed its hypotenuse and the norm and
now I look at Q times V in that same two
norm what's what's special about that
so I took any vector V and I know what
it's length is hypotenuse
now I multiply by Q what happens to the
length doesn't change doesn't change
orthogonal matrix you could think of it
as just like rotating the triangle in
space the hypotenuse doesn't change and
we've checked that because we could you
know the check is to square it and
and you're doing Q V transpose Q V and
you simplify it the usual way and then
you have Q transpose Q equal the
identity and you're golden yeah so the
result is you get the same answer as V
so let me put it in a sentence now pause
multiplying the that norm is not changed
by orthogonal matrix and these norms are
not changed by orthogonal matrices
because if I multiply the a here by an
orthogonal matrix I I have this is my a
if I multiply by by a Q and I have Q u
Sigma V transpose and what is the really
the underlying point that qu is an
orthogonal matrix just as good as you
so what if I put this down QA would be Q
u Sigma V transpose and now I'm asking
you what's the singular value
decomposition for QA and I hope I may
actually see it what's the singular
value decomposition of QA what are the
thing of their values what's the
diagonal matrix just look there for it
the diagonal matrix is Sigma what's the
goes on the right of it the V transpose
and what goes on the left of it is Q u
because that's orthogonal times
orthogonal everybody in this room has to
know that if I multiply two orthogonal
matrices the result is again orthogonal
so I can multiply by Q and it only
affects that the U part not the Sigma
part and so it doesn't change any of
those
Norm's okay so that's fine
that's what I wanted to say about the
Eckert young theorem not proving it but
but hopefully giving you an example
there of what it means that that this is
the best rank to to approximate that one
okay so that's key math behind PCA so
now I have to want to notch it not just
have to but want to tell you about PCA
so what's what's that about
so we have a bunch of data and we want
to see so let me take a bunch of data
bunch of data points say points in the
plane so I have a bunch of data points
in the plane so here's my data vector
first vector X Y well X is that a good
maybe V one these are just two component
guys me too they're just columns with
two components so I'm I'm just measuring
like height and age and I want to find
the relationship between height and age
so the first row is meant is the height
of my data and the second row is the
ages so these are so so I've got say a
lot of people these are the heights and
these are the ages and I've got n points
in 2d
and I want to make sense out of that I
want to look for the relationship
between height and age I'm actually
gonna look for a linear relation between
height and age okay so first of all
these are all over the place so the
first step that a statistician to does
is to get mean zero get the average to
be zero so what is so so all these
points are all over the place from row 1
the heights I subtract the average
height so this is a the matrix I'm
really going to work on is my matrix a
minus the average height well in all
components so this is a I'm subtracting
I'm subtracting these a mean so average
height an average age oh that was a
brilliant notation a sub a can't be a
sub you see what the matrix has done
this this matrix of two means it's just
just made each row of a now adds two now
what if I have a bunch of things and
I've subtracted off their means of the
mean or the average is now zero then
those things add up to zero right I'm
just like brought these points into
something like here this is this is age
and this is height and let's see and by
subtracting it no longer is unreasonable
to have negative age
negative height because I'm so right the
little kids when I subtract it off the
average age they ended up with a
negative age the old older ones ended up
still positive and somehow I've got a
whole lot of points but hopefully
they're they're mean is now zero do you
see that I've since I've centered the
data at zero zero and I'm looking for
what what am I looking for here I'm
looking for the best line that's what I
want to find and that would be a problem
in PCA what's the best linear relation
because PCA is limited PCA isn't all of
deep learning by any means the whole
success of deep learning was the final
realization after a bunch of years that
they had to have a nonlinear function in
there to to get to get to to model
serious data but here's PCA is a linear
business and I'm looking for the best
line and you will say wait a minute
I know how to find the best line just
use these squares Gauss did it can't be
all bad
but PCA and and I was giving a talk in
New York when I was just learning about
it and somebody said what you're doing
with PCA has to be the same as least
squares it's finding the best line and I
knew it wasn't but I didn't know how to
answer the question best and now at
least I know better so the best line in
least squares can I remind you about
these squares because this is not least
square the best line of these squares so
I have some day
points and I have a best line that goes
through them and and these squares I
don't always Center the data to mean
zero but I could but what what what do
you minimize in these squares least
square if you remember the picture in
linear algebra books of least squares
you measure the errors like the three
errors and it's how much you're wrong at
those three points those are the three
errors
a difference between a X and B the B
minus a X that you square and you add up
those three errors and what's different
over here I mean there's more points but
that's not that's not the point that's
not the difference the difference is in
PCA you're measuring perpendicular to
the line you're adding up all these
little guys squaring them so you're
adding up their squares and minimizing
so the points you see it's a different
problem and therefore it has a different
answer that and this answer turns out to
involve the SVD sigmaz where this answer
you remember from ordinary linear
algebra just when you minimize that you
got to an equation the leads leads to
one equation for the best X so do you
remember yeah what's what is it now
everybody should know yeah well I mean
and we will actually see it in this
course because we're doing the part of
linear algebra here we haven't done it
yet though and tell me again what mate
what Maitre what equation do
myself or the for that problem a
transpose a X had equal a transpose B
called the normal equations part of it
says this is a regression in in
statistics language that's a regression
problem this is a different problem okay
just so now so that involves well they
both involve a transpose a that's sort
of interesting because you have a
rectangular matrix a and then sooner or
later a transpose a is coming but this
involves solving a linear system of
equations so it's fast and we will do it
and it's very important it's probably
the most important application in 1806
but it's not the same as this one so
this is now in 1806 maybe the last day
is PCA so I didn't put those letters
principle component analysis PCA which
statins have been doing for a long time
it's we're not doing something brand new
here but the result is that we so how
does the statistician think about this
problem or that data matrix what if you
have a matrix of data two by two rows
and many columns so many many samples
what and we've made the mean 0 so that's
the first step a statistician take still
check on the mean what's the next step
what else does a statistician do with
data to measure how fit sighs there's
another number there's a number that
goes with the mean and it's the variance
the mean and the variance so somehow
we're going to do variances and it will
really be involved because we have two
sets of data Heights and ages we're
really going to have the covariance
covariance matrix and it will be 2 by 2
cause it will tell us not only the
variance in the heights that's what
first thing a statistician would think
about you know some small people some
big people and variation in ages but
also the link between them
how are the height age pairs does does
more height does more age go with more
height and of course it does that's the
whole point here so it's this covariance
matrix and that covariance matrix or the
sample covariance matrix to give it a
full name what's the so just touching on
statistics for a moment here
what's the when do we see that word
sample in the in the name what is that
telling us it's telling us that this
matrix is computed from the samples not
from a theoretical probability
distribution we might have a proposed
distribution that the height follows the
a the age while height follows the age
by some formula and that would give us a
theoretical variances we're doing sample
variances also called empirical
covariance made empirical says
empirical that word means from the
information from the data so that's what
we do and it is exactly a train a
a a transpose you have to normalize it
by the number of data points and and
then for some reason best known to
statisticians it's n minus 1 and of
course they got to be right they've been
around a long time and it should be n
minus 1 because somehow one degree of
freedom was accounted for when we took
took away the one who made the mean 0
anyway no problem but but the N minus 1
is not going to affect our computation
here that this is the matrix that tells
us that's what we were that's what we've
got to work with that's what we've got
to work with the matrix a a transpose
and then so we have this problem so we
have a yeah I guess we really have a
minimum problem we want to find yeah
what problem are we solving so our
problem was not least squares not not
the same as these squares similar but
not the same we want to minimize so
we're looking for that best line
we're age equals some number C times the
height times ya or height maybe it would
have been better to put age here and
height here no no we're cuz they're two
unknowns so I'm looking for C I'm
looking for the number C looking for the
number C and with just two minutes in
class left what is that number C gonna
be when I finally get the problem stated
properly
and then solve it I'm gonna learn that
the best ratio of age to height is Sigma
1 Sigma 1 that's so that's the one that
tells us how those two are connected and
the orthogonal and what will be the best
yeah well no maybe I didn't answer that
too right because I'm looking for I'm
looking for the vector that points in
the right way yeah I'm sorry I think the
answer is it's got to be there in the
SPD I think it's the vector you want
it's a principal component uu 1 let's do
that properly on Friday I hope you see
because this was like the first step
away from the highlights of linear
algebra two problems solved by the inner
algebra and practical problems and my
aunt my point is that the SVD saw Z's
okay